hu
[Musique]
au début du 20e siècle la population de
paris était plus importante
qu'aujourd'hui les moyens de transport
en commun faisaient déjà partie du
paysage de la ville
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme les monuments historiques les
moyens de transport appartiennent au
patrimoine parisien
[Musique]
c'est grâce à la diversité des moyens de
locomotion qu'aujourd'hui paris roule
[Musique]
depuis le 17e siècle paris dispose de
moyens de transports collectifs fiacre
omnibus tramway ce sont les chevaux qui
au début assuré la traction
bien plus tard le relais sera pris par
la mécanique
à
quand
en 1875
les premiers tramways automoteurs sont
lancés mais ce n'est qu'en 1913 que
disparaître à l'omnibus à traction
chevaline
[Musique]
cependant paris a toujours disposer
d'une voie de communication naturelle la
scène
en 1866 les bateaux qui transportait
principalement des marchandises
commencèrent à transporter des passagers
des services réguliers de bateau omnibus
déjà les bateaux mouches desservent de
nombreuses stations le long du fleuve
les voyageurs se rendent compte que vu
de la scène
la ville est encore plus belle
le palais du trocadéro
le pont-des-arts
le grand palais
la statue d'henri iv
[Musique]
e
et la conciergerie
[Musique]
le pont neuf les autobus
il sillonne paris depuis 1906
[Musique]
non
le tramway électrique
d'abord réservé à la banlieue car les
filles étaient jugées inesthétiques pour
la capitale le tramway mécanique
conquiert paris au début des années 1900
dans la circulation parisienne il est
prioritaire sur tous les autres
véhicules
mais le fait qu'il soit immergé dans le
trafic causera sa perte
il disparaîtra temporairement en 1937
[Musique]
oh
1900 un événement majeur suscite le
scepticisme le lancement du
métropolitain les parisiens ne sont pas
des taux ils descendront en jamais dans
ce trou erreur le métro est un succès
immédiat et la compagnie du chemin de
fer métropolitain attire les foules de
passagers la décision de créer ce
nouveau moyen de transport avait été
pris cinq ans plus tôt l'exposition
universelle de 1889 avait laissé un
mauvais souvenir en raison de la carence
de transport en commun
paris ne pouvait pas se permettre de
nouvelles lacunes dans la perspective
d'un événement qui devait marquer
l'entrée dans le xxème siècle
l'exposition universelle de 1900
l'exposition accueillera plus de 50
millions de visiteurs
elle sera un immense succès et
contribuera largement au rayonnement de
paris
[Musique]
trente ans plus tard l'exposition
coloniale internationale aura lieu à la
porte dorée sur le site du bois de
vincennes
[Musique]
et
l'exposition coloniale accueillera 34
millions de visiteurs en six mois
paris avait largement rattrapé son
retard en matière de moyens de
transports en commun principalement
grâce au métro qui depuis 1900 n'a cessé
de se développer
[Musique]
ce n'est qu'après quarante années
d'hésitations et de projets divers que
le 22 novembre 1895 le gouvernement
décide la création d'un métropolitain à
paris
ce sera à la ville de paris de concevoir
et développer son métro il fallait être
prêt pour le 14 avril 1900 date
d'ouverture de l'exposition universelle
les travaux furent menées à un rythme
extraordinaire
il ne fallut que dix sept mois pour
construire la ligne une qui reliait la
porte maillot à la porte de vincennes
malgré cette prouesse l'inauguration du
lieu que le 19 juillet soit avec trois
mois de retard sur l'ouverture de
l'exposition
la nature du sous-sol parisien réservé
bien des surprises
il fallut donc déployer parfois des
trésors d'imagination pour trouver des
solutions techniques adaptées
kleib la mini est spécialiste des
chemins de fer le métro de paris a une
particularité est qu'il est conçu à
faible profondeur
exactement c'est un tramway urbain qui
est simplement de construire dix à
quinze mètres plus bas que les chaussées
des rues
le système du casting code qui consiste
à faire une tranchée dans les rues à
l'époque ce qui sera le tombeau aux
idées mal et on les recouvre sa proie
avec une chaussée et pour creuser
première ligne on a suivi tout
simplement le plan des voies de
circulation
donc c'est un métro qui a coûté
relativement peu cher et qui suit les
traces et des rues qui ne passe que très
rarement sous les verrous la seule
exception celle traversée sous la serre
et les premières voitures en bois sont
conçues pour répondre aux normes d'un
chemin de fer souterrain
[Musique]
le métro devient vite très populaire
chaque ouverture de ligne sera désormais
inauguré en grande pompe et les
politiciens comprirent vite le parti
qu'il pouvait en tirer
il était bon de se montrer et de
participer aux inaugurations
[Musique]
lévrier 1920 marque une nouvelle et
importante étape dans les foires du
metropolitan paris les jours men jeunes
venus des travaux publics inaugure
solennellement d'un kilomètre de ligne
au coeur de quartiers particulièrement
peuplées comme moyen de transport c'est
en fanfare que les nouvelles lignes sont
inaugurés et georges pernoud ministre
des travaux publics
tiens à être le premier à tester les
nouvelles voies
[Musique]
au fur et à mesure que la population de
failli devenir plus d'un hectare
stipulations de l'est plaider dating
on peut puiser auprès de nouveau du net
et d'autres à chaque jour plus nombreux
en portaient les voyageurs chaque jour
plus nombreux sur les lignes du métro et
les ouvertures de stations se succèdent
de 1900 à 1937
plus de trois cent vingt stations sont
ouvertes ne laissant aucun point de
paris à plus de 400 mètres d'une bouche
de métro
[Musique]
et c'est grâce notamment à tous ces
grands travaux qu'aujourd'hui paris
roule
[Musique]
oui
le nom d'une station rappelle à lui seul
tout un pan de l'histoire du métro
montparnasse bienvenüe mais au fait
pourquoi bienvenus cultiver n'ont aucune
idée je me pense maintenant cette
question mais j'ai je connais pas la
réponse
c'est peut-être c 'est touristique pour
le tour parce que ma ville est très
accueillante
alors il me semble que c'est le créateur
dieu du métro c'est celui qui a créé le
métro à paris mais je suppose une
[Musique]
gratitude de la population parisienne a
donné le nom fulgence bienvenüe
polytechnicien ingénieur des ponts et
chaussées et breton donnera 34 ans de sa
vie à la construction et au
développement du métro
c'est lui qui décide a que toutes les
lignes serait indépendante de manière à
ce que les voyageurs n'est pas à se
demander quelle est la destination du
train quand ils entrent dans la station
l'ensemble des lits dans ce cas les
prévisions actuelles pour ont été
réalisés des pages quand 160 km pour le
réseau urbain et sera de plus de 200 km
après son extension dans le réseau de
banlieue
l'homme est tenace et ne raisonnent que
sur le long terme
en 1929 à l'âge de 77 ans il entreprend
le grand programme de prolongement des
lignes de métro en banlieue fulgence
bienvenüe prend sa retraite à 80 ans et
laisse derrière lui
l'une des plus grandes réalisations
urbaines du 20e siècle c'est une
prouesse que tous ces importantes
j'avais qu'aujourd'hui la conquête de la
lune parce qu'on est arrivé dans le
métro de paris à faire des exploits
techniques sous terre dans nos bornes
semble jamais nous avons jamais été à
l'époque exemple de prouesses techniques
la station saint-michel
il s'agissait à cet endroit de faire
traverser la seine à la ligne numéro 4
on décida de créer les éléments d'une
station en métal qui serait ensuite
enfoui dans le sol
il a fallu là aussi trouvé des solutions
ingénieuses antoine dupin directeur
territorial à la ratp
par exemple pour traverser la seine à
saint michel
on a créé une usine de congélation pour
congeler les terrains qui
qui était très mou en dessous de la
scène il fallait en effet que le sol
soit dur pour y creuser une tranchée
destiné à recevoir les énormes caisson
qui deviendront le tunnel sous la scène
il fallut immergé 5 et sont d'une
longueur totale de plus de 440 m pour
créer le tunnel ça faisait beaucoup
blues c'est énorme vaisseau n'est ce pas
est descendu comme une coque d'un navire
de la coque du titanic qui allait se
loger d'elle-même en profondeur là où et
à la voie actuelle
[Musique]
oui
autre exemple d'ingéniosité la station
gare de l'est
ici il a fallu amener le métro sous la
gare du chemin de fer c'est aussi à
cette colonne ce serait très dangereux
parce qu'elle remplace
un des piliers du bâtiment d'origine
elle permet en ce moment mais trop de
venir se loger sous l'angle de la farce
pour ce pilier est au coeur du système
très complexe
ray entre la station de métro et la gare
de l'est et l'afrique l'une accepte
l'autre ce qui n'est pas rien
[Musique]
cette station est le plus gros ouvrage
d'art de genre dans le réseau du métro
de paris avec effectivement de très
longues traverse du sport métallique qui
soutiennent la chaussée de la rue si je
montais quatre mètres plus haut je me
retrouvais directement sous les roues
des tactiques sensations des p o donc
nous sommes au coeur même d'un univers
technique très
oui
les concepteurs du métro tirait une
grande fierté de certains ouvrages qui
alliait prouesse technique et beauté
architecturale le viaduc d'austerlitz en
est un bel exemple
le défi était de franchir à la fois la
scène le port d'austerlitz et celui de
la rapée sur une distance de près de 900
m
un ouvrage de 140 m de portée entre ces
deux piliers fut réalisée en 1903 1904
le viaduc d'austerlitz surpassait ainsi
le pont alexandre iii et ses 107 mètres
cinquante de portée
[Musique]
illuminée pour son entrée dans le 21e
siècle
le viaduc d'austerlitz restera longtemps
encore un modèle de l'alliance entre le
progrès technique et l'esthétique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis plus d'un siècle concepteurs
ingénieurs et ouvriers travaillent de
concert au développement du métro en
explorant les techniques nouvelles
l'évolution technique majeur de la fin
du siècle dernier ça a été la création
d'abord du métro sur pneus on est passé
du métro faire au métro sur pneus et
également du métro automatique puisque
la ratp avec la ligne 14 a été pionnière
du du métro automatique
[Applaudissements]
pour que tout cela fonctionne il faut
bien un système de paiement et surtout
une très bonne organisation
jusque dans les années 1970 la présence
de l'homme sera indispensable à tous les
postes
il faudra des dizaines d'années pour que
la machine progressivement prennent le
relais pour certaines fonctions
pour certaines tâches l'homme était jugé
irremplaçable
jusqu'en 1971 chaque rame disposait d'un
chef de train qui jouait aussi en cas de
besoin le rôle de douceur
quant au contrôleur il a toujours été
bien présents pardon monsieur vous avez
un billet s'il vous plaît voilà c'est un
billet de deuxième classe musée de
vienne première aussi non monsieur les
billets de première classe ne sont
valables que s'ils ont été contrôlés à
l'entrée de la station
je regrette vous devez 50 fois à dame
votre billet s'il vous plaît merci s'il
vous plaît m
et quand un passager n'a pas la
conscience tranquille ça se voit et cela
facilite la tâche du contrôleur s'il
vous plaît
voilà
vous avez un billet de deuxième classe
10 minutes en première alors c'est 50
points
dans une foule aussi importante il y a
forcément quelques resquilleurs
mais les contrôleurs veille un tour de
moulinette et tout s'arrange au contact
du public
on apprend à être philosophe et pourtant
paris roule
[Musique]
m
au fil du temps les méthodes de paiement
ont évolué la poinçonneuse a été
remplacé à partir de 1972 par des
tourniquets tripode automatique
4 80 aujourd'hui la receveuse est
toujours là mais pour combien de temps
car les machines sont de plus en plus
présente
de plus en plus performantes
[Musique]
on
pour être conducteur d'autobus à la
belle époque il fallait connaître la
mécanique est bien connaître sa machine
[Musique]
car en cours de route pas question de
faire appel à une dépanneuse
[Musique]
hier comme aujourd'hui être conducteur
de bus cela présente certains avantages
surtout lorsqu'on est affecté à
certaines lignes les gens remontée des
champs-elysées
mon avis j'ai pas mal voyagé je crois
que c'est la plus belle avenue du monde
bonsoir moi j'aime bien surtout roulé
toute la période d'hiver descend
aujourd'hui
je viens tous les éclairages et où il
retrouva le touristes puis sont toujours
émerveillés mais même moi qui ferai tous
les ont donc depuis 25 ans moi j'ai
toujours ça va arriver mais des points
de l'arrêté puis de prendre des photos
et oui certains machinistes sont aussi
photographe
[Musique]
à
pour être traminots conducteur de
tramway
il fallait aussi être polyvalent et bien
connaître son véhicule
même si le tramway était prioritaire il
ne fallait pas à paris dépasser les 20
km heure il fallait aussi négocier
prudemment les bifurcations pour ne pas
trop secouer les passagers
conduire un tramway aujourd'hui est-ce
plus simples ou plus compliqué c'est
vrai que la première fois que je suis
parti en formation
j'avais l'impression que c'était
compliqué et puis en fait avec une bonne
formation
ça se conduit en simplement en fait les
boutons qu'on voit c'est surtout des
boutons pour ce qui est de manipuler les
feux aux carrefours ou à manipuler les
portes les évêques les ouvertures et
fermetures de porc sous terre
d'autres rails d'autres conducteurs
autrefois le conducteur de métro
devaient être français avoir fait son
service militaire
avoir une taille minimum de 1 m 60 il
travaillait 9h45 par jour avec un jour
de repos tous les huit jours
aujourd'hui tout cela a un peu changé
[Musique]
mais bon on garde quand même à caractère
on veut dire professionnels d'après moi
[Musique]
oh
des moyens de transport sans incidents à
paris ou ailleurs ça n'a jamais existé
il y a les collisions les défaillances
mécaniques les trajectoires qui mouille
les dérapages plus ou moins contrôlés
[Musique]
les débuts d'un 110 les déraillements
ans
je
le brouillard où intervient le bateau
pilote pour éviter toute mauvaise
surprise
il suffisait de suivre le bâton ou
encore les inondations comme la crue de
[Musique]
le chef de station a toujours eu un rôle
clé au niveau de la sécurité
il assure notamment la liaison avec le
chef de ligne et le poste de contrôle
qui réagit en cas d'incident
[Musique]
à granby et écoles militaires commandés
si on l'appliquait madeleine au
dégagement de fumée à 434 l aurais un
matricule 23 27 ch surveillants donne
l'ordre à 21,52 leur met des courants
sur la section la motte piquet madeleine
ou par être mise en place
aujourd'hui c'est le même principe avec
un matériel un peu plus moderne
nec plus ultra de la technologie la
ligne météores la ligne 14 par exemple
est entièrement automatique
[Musique]
cinq cent mille passagers l'empruntent
chaque jour sous le regard des caméras
du pcc le poste de commande et de
contrôle
[Musique]
nombre de passagers du métro en 1917
millions 700 mille nombre de passagers
un an plus tard près de 60 millions
nombre de passagers aujourd'hui près de
1 milliard 50 millions par an mais c'est
en 1945
l'année de la fin de la guerre que tous
les records ont été battus plus de 1
milliard 500 millions de passagers
[Musique]
sympa voici le sonim metropolit au pôle
hippolytains métropole lee ben oui le
visage de la capitale n'est pas celui là
rue pigalle
c'est sale argent le jeu l'amour la vie
de tous les jours c'est monsieur étourdi
solesmes et guitry
et solide
même
le métro est un lieu de vie depuis
l'origine le métro parisien est
fréquenté par des musiciens à la
recherche d'une reconnaissance
artistique et d'un lieu d'expression
aujourd'hui 300 musiciens sont
accrédités et pas n'importe lesquels
j'ai fait les premières parties des
séries tout ça tout ça je vous le saviez
du métro
c'est une école salle de répétition et
et 5 ou d'actions dans son pays de métro
les aînés
pour vraiment chanté par c'est
d'accrocher chacun chacun qui passe
faisons parce que quand on joue en
concert les gens ils ont payé donc me
vient absolument ils vont voir concert
si mauvais ou pas mauvais mais quand on
joue dans le métro crise ça les
intéresse pas voilà chaque on passe on
est pressé et celui qui reste qui écoute
c'est que vraiment ça l'intéresse c'est
que vraiment telle approche je vous dis
papa papa papa
et toujours par y roule
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le métro est un monde fermé
il lui fallait d ouverture vers
l'extérieur des ouvertures sur le rêve
une des solutions la publicité a tiré
par un public captif extrêmement
important
[Musique]
en quoi le tour de la terre en épave ou
taboulé parcours quotidien des trains en
service
on arrive à un total de 80 mille
kilomètres il ya toujours eu beaucoup de
trafic
le trafic le plus important ratp était
au sortir de la guerre un de 42 45 et on
a retrouvé ce pic de trafic très
important dans les années quatre-vingt
dix-huit 2000 et c'est sûr que c'est
c'est cette audience comme ils viennent
chercher des annonceurs dans ces lieux
là norbert maire et directeur innovation
métrobus publicité pour lui la publicité
d'un métro a toujours répondu à deux
impératifs l'animation des lieux et la
rentabilité
donc là l'idée c'est évidemment de faire
vivre deux du côté ratp les espaces et
de les valoriser
évidemment pour avoir des recettes
supplémentaires aux recettes transports
certaines publicités du métro mérite de
figurer en bonne place dans le
patrimoine parisien
car la publicité ne s'est pas limité à
la simple affiche ya eu de la peinture
sur les murs il ya eu du carrelage il ya
eu des tas d'exploitation très
différente de l'espace
[Musique]
le métro est un monde un espace de vie
tu dois être entretenues et la nuit
depuis toujours on briques et on a stick
[Musique]
pour
oh
[Musique]
pour éviter le stress
il faut que l'univers du métro souhaite
aussi un lieu de plaisir et surtout
qu'ils répondent à une logique you came
in haggaï responsable du design à la
ratp
je compare souvent l'espace de transport
à une sorte de scène de théâtre où des
personnages doivent participer à une
pièce et sièges systèmes d'information
une signalétique un matériel roulant
tous ces éléments sont des personnages
de de la scène du transport urbain que
le voyageur spectateurs finalement et
participant au spectacle même regarde
oui
le métro est en quelque sorte un
spectacle un spectacle qui n'est pas
toujours facile à monter la difficulté
que ces personnages sont générés par des
metteurs en scène d'époques différentes
il ya peut-être plusieurs metteurs en
scène donc nous on est le metteur en
scène des metteurs en scène finalement
on coordonne l'ensemble des personnages
pour que l'histoire soit vraisemblable
est que dans le parcours du voyageur
les choses s'enchaînent de la façon la
plus logique et la plus facile possible
rien de plus logique aussi que de
concevoir certaines stations en fonction
du pari de la surface la station louvre
est exemplaire
un pied hors de la ram et le voyageur a
déjà l'impression d'être dans l'un des
sanctuaires de la culture mondiale ou la
station tuileries considéré comme
station patrimoine au mur décollage
illustrant l'histoire de chacune des
décennies du xxème siècle pour les
années 40
la rencontre entre charlie chaplin et
bécassine la station concorde est
recouverte d'un scrabble géant qui
assemble les lettres de la déclaration
des droits de l'homme
la voûte de la station cluny la sorbonne
est couverte des signatures de
célébrités du quartier latin arts et
métiers est l'antichambre du musée dédié
à la science et à la technique on se
retrouve transporté dans l'univers du
nautilus de jules verne
[Musique]
ap ap
à
non
elles sont inimitables on ne peut
visiter paris sans remarquer les lignes
courbes de ses entrées de métro de style
art nouveau
elles sont signées par l'architecte à
hector guimard qui travaillait pour le
compte de la compagnie du métro parisien
avec un objectif de communication s'est
donné une image au métro qui soit une
image extrêmement moderne d'une utopie
réalisée alors que à l'époque le métro
faisait peur oui au début certains
pensaient que les parisiens auraient
peur d'emprunter le métro
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
guimard a misé sur une esthétique qui
rassure mais le style dit marc ne
plaisait pas à tout le monde et celui
que l'on surnomme le chantre de l'art
nouveau furent remerciés par la
compagnie du métro parisien en 1904
aujourd'hui son oeuvre fait partie du
patrimoine culturel parisien
les éléments des 86 entrée qui
subsistent sur les cent quarante et une
qui ont été construites sont
soigneusement entretenue par des
compagnons qui dispose toujours des
moules d'origine
[Musique]
ne les cherchez pas sur le plan de paris
ces stations qui s'appelle martin nadaud
qu'ils appellent axe on sait bel arsenal
sont des stations qui ont existé une
semaine et poke et qui ont fermé ces
stations fantômes parfois elles n'ont
jamais ouvert
c'est le cas par exemple de la station
ax haut on a créé les quais mais on n'a
jamais ouvert les escaliers la
raccordant à la surface dans un appel du
stationnement non
rouge sur la ligne 10 oui la station
croix rouge et fermé depuis 1939 et
n'est plus fréquenté que par les
fantômes
des fantômes qui ont parfois l'occasion
de s'initier à l'art moderne et à la
culture
malgré pour ses prestations comme le
relis mes attaques et l'opportunité
d'accueillir de temps en temps des
animations culturelles
comme à partir des années 80 ici on n'a
qu'une plage et
et en 2008 on a une
[Musique]
il
après ces manifestations la station
croix rouge et restituer à ses fantômes
nous avons également et ça c'est
important
une station porte des lilas qui est une
station qui n'est pas utilisé et qui
sert aux tournages de films lorsque le
métro parisien apparaît au cinéma il est
fort probable que les images étaient
tournées ici
cette station est bien sûr appropriées
en fonction du décor voulue par le
réalisateur et elle sert ainsi à dos
grand film je pense par exemple à la
grosse caisse avec bros ville qui dans
les années 60 a permis de découvrir les
coulisses du métro
[Musique]
entre deux tournages les fantômes
peuvent dormir tranquilles car ces
stations ne sont pas accessibles au
public et il faut que son secret cette
occasion c'est plus
une atmosphère pensez-y avec ces images
[Musique]
les stations vivent elles naissent et
parfois aussi elle même
moment très d'un village mon coeur des
biens paris
d'où la mise en jeu son deuil
sa famille
[Musique]
ici les gens de l'autre une fille de
rien
don
un matin je
[Musique]
omettre un bilan
ok
le péage sans chanter pour
là ça craint finie la place de terre
ça
on n'a pas un mirage et quand
[Musique]
et toujours par y roule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
c'est
[Applaudissements]
le chanteur yves montand disait dans la
ballade de paris les années ont passé
doucement mais paris a gardé ses 20 ans
la scène a creusé son lit entre les
quais tout gris de paris
il faut croire qu'elle s'y trouve bien
puisqu'elle est encore là aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
le long de la seine sens with so swing
ensuite sweet micky famille
je suis amoureux de vaud suisse
paris
il permet d'enrichir
i'm in love my swing
je suis allemand
ce we are u
paris paris chéri iam est là
[Musique]
mon genou n'est pas
arriva michel
je suis amoureux de vous